(crowd cheering)
- Love your outfit.
You look so fantastic.
- [Hoda Kotb] Wait.
- [Kelly] What, did you find some kind of
fountain of youth or
tree that I should visit?
- First of all, you have a show!
- I have a show!
(crowd cheering)
- Remember I was on I
was on "The Today Show",
and this was before it was announced,
and it was in the works and nobody knew.
And you and Kathie were like,
"You should have a TV show."
- [Hoda] By the way.
- And I was like, "No."
- We, but I have to say we predicted.
- You did.
- Kelly was gonna have
a show a long time ago.
- I thought you were nuts.
- You showed up on our set
and you lit the place up.
Like nobody ever had.
- Well.
- And I didn't forget it.
And I remember thinking
like what's gonna happen.
And when Kathie Lee was leaving, remember?
- Yes!
- We were like, what's gonna happen?
We were unclear.
- I know and here's the sad thing like,
I was like, wait, I didn't realize,
at the time, that she was leaving.
And I was like, "I could've
maybe gotten to work with you."
I was like, "What?"
And then I was like, "Wait,
you wake up really early."
(laughing)
I was like, "Nope."
- But you've been, I have to tell you,
we watch you all the time.
- Thank you.
- You've been amazing.
- I love it.
- And I'm so happy for
you I can't even express.
- And now you work with
my other Texas queen.
- Jenna.
- Come on.
- Jenna Bush Hager is cray.
- So funny.
- And so fun.
- Miss Texan.
It's sad I'm sorry.
So, welcome but wait,
one reason why I'm glad
you're here is well #wine.
Let's do this.
- #wine!
- Yep, yep. I mean because
you get to drink on your show.
So, here's what I'm gonna toast to.
- Okay.
- This is actually pretty cool.
Let's toast from my friends at ACME Wine.
- Okay.
- Okay, it's a Matt Morris,
I think it's called Charbono.
- Look at you.
- I know I'm so French.
Um, I don't even know what
it is and it's actually
a female just won like
winemaker of the year.
So, it's really amazing.
Supporting females.
I thought it was really rad.
We both like wine.
We both love supporting females.
- Yes we do.
- So, I thought it worked.
- By the way, this is perfect.
- [Kelly] It's so good.
- Do you drink on your show often?
- I love that you're
here, 'cause I don't get.
Well, here's the thing.
- [Hoda] What, tell me.
- I think my people learned.
- [Hoda] Yeah.
- Mama's a lightweight.
And like they have, you
know you have your demos.
- Yeah.
- Well, I thought at first
it was gonna be like fake like water.
Nope, nope, it's real.
So, everybody brings like
their alcohol on air.
And like, yeah I'll try it.
And like literally, I'm like
hot and I'm like, "Focus."
I'm like such a lightweight, it's weird.
Like no matter how much I drink in life,
I will never be able to drink more than
one or two glasses.
Or it's like hold my hair.
- Hold my hair (laughs).
- And it's my husband's worst night ever.
But wait, you have a new show and you
and Jenna, you're going in
front of a live audience now.
- Well, we took a page from you.
This is perfect.
So, today was our very
first day of having a live
audience and I have to say we
have like, I love this vibe.
I love the vibe you have on your show
and Jenna and I have always
said like we love our
cameramen, Rope and Anthony.
We love them.
We love when they laugh.
- Yeah, you play off of them almost. Yeah.
- But there's something about having
like our people with us.
- An energy of it, yeah.
- Yes.
So, we've been excited about this.
We wanna do it five days a week.
We're gonna start with
two just to get it going.
And we're pumped, man.
We feel like it's gonna be a good phase.
- I think it's great
because people love you.
They love Jenna, but they've
loved you for years on TV.
And it's awesome to give people a chance
to be in the same room with you.
- To hang out.
- And like feed off your energy.
And you're kind of like me.
You talk to everyone and so does Jenna.
- Yes.
- So, your gonna love it.
- [Hoda] I can't wait.
- It's so great.
- Yes. I love it.
- I feed off the energy as well.
But how has becoming a
mom changed you though?
Because you love kids.
Now, you have your second baby.
Yes.
- You know what, Kelly.
It's like (crowd cheers).
Thank you.
I keep trying to remember
my life before them.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And I can't.
It is so.
- [Kelly] Filled.
- I feel like it all started.
And it's so strange to even think this,
but um, I remember the
first time someone asked me.
I was walking to Duane Reade
after I had just adopted Haley.
And I'd been.
My whole life people had
asked me the question,
"Do you have children?"
and I've always said,
"Oh, I have two nieces."
And I remember saying it in my sleep.
And I love my nieces.
- I used to do that too.
"Oh, my niece and my nephew."
Yeah, yeah.
- Yes. So, I was walking and she said,
"Do you have children?"
And I hadn't really told anybody.
And I stopped and I said,
"I have a daughter."
And she looked at me.
- You are Oprahing me right now.
Like, wow.
- But she looked at me and I said,
"I have a daughter." I kept repeating it.
"I have a daughter."
And it was so profound
to me in that moment.
And when we were thinking about whether
we should adopt another child,
I mean there are pluses to
having children late in life.
And obviously there are minuses.
Um, but I kept thinking I want someone
to hold hands with.
I want these two to have someone
to hold hands with all the way.
Like, they have older
parents and I know that
that's the way life goes.
But I wanna know when they are later on
in life there's somebody
who says I remember.
- Yeah.
- Like, I remember, yeah.
- My gosh, you are seriously
about to make me ball.
That's so beautiful.
That was, I.
We have older ones and
we have two younger ones
and I was like I hated
pregnancy but I was like
god, I don't want her to be alone.
- Yes.
- You know, I was alone a lot as a kid.
And I was like, I don't
want her to do that.
You know.
- Yes you want someone.
- 'Cause I'm nuts and I
don't want her to be nuts.
But the other news.
This is actually fantastic.
- [Hoda] What?
- I have thought you were
married this whole time.
Like, you're newly engaged.
And I'm like, "Congratulations!"
But I was like, "What?"
Anytime you send me
videos of like drinking
with your man or like you're on vacation.
First, I'm like, I want
your life and then like
I thought you were
married this whole time.
- Yes, you know what's funny.
- They were like, "Oh, she got engaged."
I was like, "To another person?" or like,
"Is she divorced?"
Like why?
What?
- You know what, Joel,
I met Joel like randomly
at a book signing one
day like six years ago.
And it was one of those crazy nights
that you're so happy you went out.
We started dating and a few years in
all I was thinking about was having kids
and I couldn't push it away.
And when I asked him
and I brought this up,
I said, "I can't push it away anymore."
I said, "I have to ask you
this important question."
I said, "Will you explore
adoption with me?"
And literally without
blinking, without pausing,
he looked at me and he
said, "yes, yes, yes."
- I love him.
- So, I already knew
he loved me that much.
So, I kind of didn't care
about the married part.
I was like okay we're in
love, we have two kids.
Like, who cares.
It did matter to him, I think a lot.
And one day we were at the beach.
And it was just the two of
us having a mom and dad trip.
And he started giving.
- I love mom and dad trips.
- We were having tequila and
churros, we were in Mexico.
- Girl.
- I was like I'm so happy.
- I love an adult trip.
- And he was kind of giving
a little like love speech
which he does sometimes.
Like, let's talk about where we are
and I love when he does that.
And I was like, "Oh, that's so cute."
And I had another tequila
and was like licking the.
And then he was like, and then he goes,
"I really have something important
that I would like to say."
I said, "Yes, I love all of
your talks about love, yes."
And I was buzzed.
- [Kelly] Feeling slightly hammered, yeah.
- I was so happy.
- You're like yes I love us.
- And then he kicked the chair
out and he got on a knee.
And he was crying and I was crying.
And I didn't even, he
goes, "Did you say yes?"
I said, "Did you ask?" like I couldn't.
It was too much.
But anyway,
and in that moment I thought I'd feel
like I did the day before
'cause I already loved him.
But I had no idea how profound
saying something out loud is like that.
- And telling other people.
- Yes.
- There's something to that as well 'cause
I was like you.
Well, first of all, my mom
is still shocked that I'm
married and have children.
So, I just didn't think
that was gonna happen.
But it's just one of those
things that, you know,
didn't matter to me as much as it mattered
to my husband and kids,
he was like, you know
and then he thought "I don't
know, I think it's important."
You know, and I was like,
"Oh, I'm cool with it."
And he, you know, popped
the question one day.
But once it does happen,
you're like, "Oh no, that is different."
- Yes.
- [Kelly] It's different than
just being together and in love.
- It's a really cool
declaration in front of everyone
and you know just a real like,
"Nah, hell no, stay away from my man."
You know?
It's a nice, it's a nice thing a ring.
- You know what, it does
change. I didn't know.
So, we're like.
- I agree.
- Here, we go, look at us.
- I just love that you've been married
in my world for years.
- Well, I was married
once before a while ago.
- No, no, I thought to him.
- Oh, to him.
- 'Cause you send me videos
when you're on vacation
and I'm like, "I love them,
"They're the best married couple."
- By the way, I love drunk texting Kelly.
When we're out, I'm like,
"Hey, Kelly, It's us."
- It's my favorite.
- You're probably like,
"What is she doing?"
- No, I have a few
friends in the limelight
that randomly do that.
Pentatonix are one as well.
And it's great.
Yeah, I'm like, "Y'all should
"not do this, this is
blackmail," uh huh, blackmail.
I was like, I never do that.
I'm afraid people will show it.
Never send that to Blake Shelton.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
Never.
I know you love Blake but he will take.
- But I don't trust.
- Never trust him with something
important footage-wise.
- [Hoda] What did you do, did he do some.
- No I just don't trust him.